[Musica]
sento tipo sento male sento tanto vale
però fare la mia intra e poi ve lo
stacco perchè giuro è un'agonia pazzesca
del dio se fa male a tutti i ragazzi
benvenuti questo video sono fa vj oggi
schiavino blog [ __ ] i segni che mi
rimarranno sulla pelle la mia bellissima
pelle per tutta la vita
belle affitti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj a chi
siamo il nuovo ai ragazzi allora pareva
dirvi una cosa prima di cominciare
emotivo e mi fanno spesso la domanda
farli ma ti è capitato ma gli registrare
qualcosa che poi non si salva in qualche
modo con che il file viene corrotto
insomma qualcosa che registra e poi non
non posso mettere perché ho perso i file
un'oretta fa ha iniziato a registrare il
blog di oggi in questo preciso momento
circa 5 minuti fa ho scoperto che l'odio
che registrata un'ora fa che ho fatto
perché o se anche guardate ciò anche
stati parchi tutto quanto è andato tutto
a [ __ ]
quindi quello sarebbe il momento
migliore per rispondere alla domanda ma
fallì ma che cosa provi quando tipo ti
si cancellano i file di registrazione un
appello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuto che
sono video sono fa vj elogi siamo il
nuovo blog per la seconda volta prima di
cominciare con solito l'idea di iniziare
con la faber della settimana che questa
settimana ragazzi è stata vinta da
valentina è affatto questo disegno a
parte il fatto che il cappello
bellissimo va bene il tatuaggio
mascolino e del fisico da vries le però
perché o lo smalto passando le news
ragazzi sabato prossimo ci sarà la live
di mtv al alla reggia di venaria di
torino come avevo già detto nel suo blog
coltivo e mi hanno chiesto la lario che
avevo detto comunque malori dico perché
molti sono perso non so come ci sono
ragazzi sabato prossimo 13 settembre
quindi alle 4 alle quattro di pomeriggio
e non è 43 per col cazzo io non ho
ancora realizzato che veramente vado
anche c'è una cosa ancora incredibile
per me io finché non sono lì non
realizzo vero ci sarete in tanti ragazzi
voglio abbracciare 1 a 1 anche gente che
non conosca braccio non avevo perché mi
sento c'è una cosa pazzesca ragazzino
non vedo veramente l'ora con creazioni
arrivato mi arrivato questo la scorsa
settimana che è una figata pazzesca come
braccialetto a mio parere che bei pelle
ero troppo felice vista cosa quindi
dovevo farlo non c'entra una mazza prova
benedetto queste ragazzine che possiamo
passare allo scarto dei partner e questo
è un problema perché si che ho già
scartato i pacchi e non mi ha registrato
come il pezzo perché se pensate di fare
una cosa vi faccio vedere direttamente
che cosa mi ha regalato così almeno dice
molto ragazzi pizzo che vedete
supermario la prova nei castelli pc io
invece la trovo nei pacchi direttamente
dopo pc ragazzi ho ricevuto l'ultimo di
lupin iii che va beh e poi i magic
english che non ho capito se ne avete
regalato perché non parlo bene l'inglese
cosa del genere non perché ma my english
is meglio che io avevo visto cazzo non
trova trovato un cosa che non avevo
aperto incredibile safavi spero che il e
poi poi ha censurato dei qua dentro ti
piaccia spero che tu non lo abbia già
qualsiasi cosa sia sei tranquillo e la
casa non hai questo non avevo scartato
no no brega
cydia 56 ce l'avevo già però arriva una
casa mia mi chiedeva mamma mia che piace
gt aioliko guarda mi piace talmente
tanto da quando ho finito la lori
comprato perché valori giocavo vi
ringrazio ragazzi quindi scatta scambio
gt ha usato e poi ragazzi avete regalato
un cubo di rubik tra l'altro che però
non c'ho voglia di fare proprio grazie
il cuore
[Musica]
mancavano due pezzi ragazzi però grazie
di cuore come ultimo ragazzi da troppi
china e una posizione bellissima non so
se come ultimo ragazzi ho trovato questo
devi pronti perché questa rete e
tecnologia con ragazzi intento questo
l'ho scartato dei pacchi e fini era
finito ragazzine che possiamo passare al
farmi risponde ancora non ho capito
perché faccio così quando 9 comunque
ragazzi nel video di prima era gli otto
fino a questo punto poi fave risponde
non l'ho fatto perché mi ha lasciato il
computer non andare a dormire incazzata
prima domanda ragazzi arrivano a lei
divampa york e mi chiede però in fondo
c'è un libro che se leggendo in questo
periodo a capo anno iniziata l'estate
più o meno inizia a leggere il labirinto
che è un specie di romanzo 6.000 hunger
games più o meno sia tipo il film il 10
ottobre di questo mezzo runner quindi mi
sono tipo buttato sulla lettura in un
modo tipo intanto qualcosa di traverso
merda sto lacrimando pure ma lantieri fi
risponda somiglia muso uno che fa step
up sarà amy mi sembra alquanto ok io gli
assomiglia ray a questo qui in ama tipo
ci prendiamo per il culo vasta
somiglianza dove diavolo la vedete le
cacia
[Musica]
unico problema è che io sono tipo
diversamente bravo a ballare
[Musica]
no io
roma fa vi risponde che collana è quella
che nelle foto ti si vede al collo ogni
tanto questi primi venti ragazzi sono e
sono idonei delle torte che presente
sarebbe tipo a questa è la candelina sta
in mezzo dice che ragazzi invece la
presente la forma della torta mentre la
il triangolo è la la glassa che la
ricopre significativa quindi la
l'apporto spesso colui che non deve
essere festeggiato un altra cosa ragazzi
cioè non è una domanda però devono
assolutamente di eva presente nello
stesso blog come saw vi domando ragazzi
che fatto vi piace più i fari risponde
allo scarto dei pacchi e in realtà sta
mia domanda è stata una specie di
trabocchetto perché adesso ci cascava te
e ha funzionato ma vi domanda preferisco
decisamente i pacchi che torno pieno di
commenti
ho passato la nottata a ridere con il
film ragazzine di rifare la fabi domanda
salatamente trabocchetti che lo è stato
l'unico e la fabi domanda di questa
volta ragazzi secondo voi visto che mi
si è cancellato il blog prima di fare
questo con chi me lo andrò a prendere
secondo voi ragazzi alla risposta a chi
è mario risposta bis land risposta chip
bruno mars punti ragazzi ray che possono
chiudere qui il video
siccome è un ho ancora abbastanza
incazzato da prima con che succede mi è
successo anche altre volte solo che
stavolta si tratta di un blog quindi ho
potuto rifarlo capita una volta ogni
secolo da quando capita male botta al
computer ragazzi servito è piaciuto è se
anche voi pensate che idonei delle torte
siano i fondamentali lasciate un
commento mi piace anche a pagare
facebook e come non i video fratello
descrizione se non sapresti discreto lì
ci vediamo al prossimo video bello
ragazzi